a couple of months ago we talked about
Bayonetta to be antenna to 10 do you
remember that oh yeah I remember that
totes yeah just got our 9th 10 out of 10
Kevin Vanna or The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt
who we and out of 10 I've been waiting
for this moment we have a bunch of
questions from people who have sent them
in asking specifics that we either
mention in your review or not Chris
waters well prepared I'll try to stay on
topic before we get to the granularity
let it let us know what you think about
Witcher 3 in terms of the broad strokes
why isn't Anton sprigle game that's
alright you played on ps4 10 out of time
so Witcher 3 Wild Hunt is one of the
best video games ever made when it said
in the front page GameSpot calm I woke
up to see Kevin van Ord I really love
this game
oh god it's still going to comments and
just pop and I don't worry about that
haha umm I really really love this game
I think it's the standard setter for all
not just like character focused RPGs but
for open worlds in general I think it's
a little icy like some people saying you
know what's it like compared to Skyrim I
think it's a little unfair Skyrim is a
sandbox up which was reason a sandbox
but I think in terms of character
focused open-world RPGs
this is as good as it gets it's special
and you're showing one of my very
favorite scenes in the entire game which
has nothing to do with killing monsters
but it's just sitting in a pub listening
to the true Barrett's sing as a female
trovador troubadour I like it I didn't
know that word exists until right now
yeah I didn't either until I until I
played The Witcher 3 and then I expanded
my vocabulary now I know both plowing
yes
hence true Brits I'm plowing therefore
what I've done and your review is
currently up on GameSpot calm but a
bunch of people sent in questions myself
and Chris are going to lay them on you
right now do my best first one is from
our V that's at Harvey underscore X on
Twitter and newcomer here is it
necessary to have played the previous
installments to understand the overall
plot of wild hum now no I mean I mean
obviously it helps somewhat you already
have some sense of connection with
characters and you already sort of know
what hap
but not only does the game give you an
effects position so that you more or
less know what's going on but frankly in
the previous games the politics ended up
being a little bit abstract there wasn't
a whole lot of personal connection yeah
to them and this game creates a personal
connection and I think it's much easier
as a result to relate to what's going on
than in any of the previous games so
it's not just about the nilfgaard and
the land grabbing it's got a lot of that
stuff but because you have such a
personal connection with most of these
things and you develop if you don't have
a pre-existing one you develop them in
the game and as a result they just sort
of it just sort of builds naturally I
don't think you need to know that stuff
is always it helps but cool well let's
talk about length of a Nord because Elia
Lassalle wants know approximately how
many hours did you sort of did you'd
knock into it before writing the review
and did you have to did you find
yourself
skipping parts or just like sort of
leaving things to the side in the
interest of time well there I mean yes
in a sense I spent about a hundred hours
with the game and that that involved
playing bunches and bunches of side
stuff not because I was in a hurry
though I didn't do anything because I
was hurrying I did it because I just
played the game I would ordinarily play
it yeah I got lucky Sunday night I
finished the story but there is one
thing to note is that the stories have
you know the story quests have
recommended levels so there is going to
be some stuff that you do on the side
just by nature you're going to need to
do that if you want to be at the right
level for the story um but overall I'd
say that I bet you most people would
probably get about the same in just an
ordinary playthrough but the good news
is that if you don't do all that stuff
in your first playthrough when you
finish the story you get to go back into
the world and then do whatever you want
and there's a lot of stuff out there at
a much higher level like I think max
level might be 50 what was your like 60
30 I finished effects 35 36
I think his max level is 60 but the
quest level up to my 50 right though
there's a lot of stuff there was stuff
that was beyond my level when I finished
the game awesome I haven't gone back
simply because I want to start again
because one of the sad news about the
debug version that I played for Hugh is
no trophies Oh
I don't want to start again and get
trophy achievements or whatever and next
question from Augustine he asks how much
time do you play as Siri I would say
overall you end up playing about I don't
know
gosh four hours as Siri sick most of the
series segments are in flashback okay
let's keep it non spoilery it's I
definitely keeping it non spoilery so
most of the series segments are played
as a flashback yep um and and that's
that's about it I mean it's she's not
really I mean Geralt is the star most of
the stuff is Siri is just like getting a
chance to know her yes people remember
their experiences with her that's kind
of how that's set up cool uh witcher 2
had like a pretty significant learning
curve for combat and sort of prepping
and whatnot but christopher at the gamer
mode has never played a Witcher game and
wants to know what the learning curve is
like for The Witcher 3
not much um The Witcher 2 was infamously
difficult to wrap your head around when
you try to do the combat like I died so
many times in the first combat scenario
in The Witcher 2 The Witcher 3 is much
more fluid I think there's there's
actually a downside and that it can get
a little easy one of the witcher 2 was
like weirdly difficult when it starts
the witcher 3 is actually easy enough
that eventually I cranked up there are
four difficulty notches and I started
with the one that it defaults to which
is number two yeah I cranked it up to
number three um it like about a quarter
of the way through because things were
just a little too easy we recommended
that in your review I did I did and then
I feel like it hits about the right it
still you know you can still easily out
level the story quests if you do that if
you're doing a lot of side stuff and
then find the story quests kind of easy
um but the thing I like about the combat
is even when things get easy you still
have to exercise a certain level of
tactics because like here's here you see
on the screen like a drowner like
typically those attack in big waves like
as do wolves so you have to be careful
you can't do necessarily the thing like
you can't hold down and spray fire
because they're just gonna keep
interrupting you so you have to you do
have to exercise different types of
I'm one of the things actually just to
get off the questions for a second that
you mentioned earlier today was that in
the most difficult modes the cooldowns
or the like the casting times for spells
changing time changes I like then you
know when it comes to difficulty levels
it's not just about oh the enemies have
more hit points and you have more hit
points and I like the fact that some you
know some of the the castings beats
change like there's one sign where you
can take over an enemy's mind and it
later levels you can make them fight for
you yeah but if on the second difficulty
mode you basically just activate it
right away on the third you actually
have to hold it down until it takes
we're cool so that's that's actually
kind of nice I really appreciated that
and next question at pope GTR asks I
played the past two games on PC and
Netta sided switched ps4 well I miss
anything by not uploading my old save
files okay so this is interesting
actually this is an interesting thing
supposedly on the PC version it looks at
your save files and knows I haven't been
able to test that the good news is that
whether you play on PC or on consoles
you get a chance it's there's this whole
sequence where you talk to a King's
advisor who asks you questions about the
past and in this scene you get to decide
what what those Witcher 2 decisions are
going to be like for you and The Witcher
3 moving forward so if you don't carry
over the save then you have an
opportunity remember how like Mass
Effect when it came to new platforms
have a little comic thing where you
could sort of decide and this isn't an
in-game example of something like that
where it's like so just for the record
how did you do this thing so I played
that not like I did not play much of The
Witcher 2 at all so I played that me was
asking me the questions and I had
literally no context for a I was just
kind of picking randomly was that the
case when you were playing it as well
well no because I had made I mean when I
played the PC version I had already made
those decisions so I knew what they
meant and you remembered them as well
and I remembered them yeah so for what
it's worth those do have a meaning okay
you have meaning in The Witcher 3 I
can't say what all the meanings are
because I only played in that particular
way with my decisions of course um but I
am going to be putting together
for what it's worth a little a little
feature that shows that scene and
explains what the background is for
those designs for people that are new so
people who want to make sure Rex is
alive in The Witcher 3 exactly so so
let's say you didn't know who Rex was um
let's say it's the equivalent of that
I'm putting together a little little
little written thing with some video
cool explaining what the background of
these choices are for people that don't
know what they mean
excellent Kevin you played this game for
a hundred hours yeah now you want to go
back and start anew
you mentioned trophies but like are you
you know do you let's say you were
playing this and you've gotten your
trophies you played 300 hours on the ps4
is there motivation to keep playing
Chris one three three seven one so no
yes one of my biggest I mean it's weird
because on one hand when you're a
reviewer I had about what nine days to
play this yeah hundred hours and nine
days plus on top of everything else I
was doing god that sunset oh but you
know one of the things is gosh will I
ever finish this you know I don't I
don't play games in a different way than
I for review than I would otherwise like
I basically play it I mean I might be
working a lot of hours to do it but I
don't choose different things I don't
like Pat it or I don't try to rush I
just play it like I would play it and so
you know a hundred hours seems about
right
what was the question again and did you
I'm completed it that was the second
half of my regret is I got to the end
it's like now all I want to do is run
around into all that other stuff I look
at the map and I see a trillion question
marks out there yeah that I never got to
see but it's not really about I make
this point Roo it's not really about
marking off those things like okay I did
this and I did this and I'm gonna 100%
this this thing here and one of it
wasn't about that it was because I knew
that there would be really cool stuff
out there like I felt like I was really
missing so many other secrets can I tell
a little story go for it real quick I
tell this little story in the review but
I love this this bit and this gives you
an idea of what it's like so and spoiler
free there's a decision you make where
somebody ends up you end up uncovering a
crime and this this person gets
sentenced to death and you watch you
watch her get sentenced to death she's
sentenced to starve
by getting tied
on an island farm so this is a this is a
thing that may or may not happen
depending on what you know the things
you you want to do in The Witcher 3 so I
watched this and then it was over
right so hours and hours later I'm
sailing through um these islands there's
you know you get to pilot a boat go
through find the sky legs yeah and so I
just randomly I'm coming across this
this little island and there's a body
chained to like a you know a stone or
something I'm like what the hell is this
so I get out to look and garel starts
talking about God you know here's here's
the body of so and so yeah you know and
like that's the kind of thing that
happens like it wasn't scripted the game
didn't force me to go out and stare at
her bottom may never have seen it yeah I
may never have seen it but I love the
fact that somebody went that extra mile
they thought to themselves oh good you
know they thought to themselves hey this
is a thing that should happen we're not
just gonna make her disappear
we're gonna give you the opportunity
potentially see the consequences right
what you did and even though when you
when I did it I felt like it was right I
still felt like was justified and right
that's kind of what this world is about
even when you do what the lesser of
Evil's there's always some kind of
horrific consequence and if the game
didn't feed it to me it didn't force it
on me it just allowed it to happen and
that's I think that's very special it's
the way choices work in The Witcher 3 in
general is it just sort of allows them
to happen it's not parading around oh
look you made this choice and we're
putting them all in these little boxes
yeah so that you know this is a choice
and this is the the container where this
choice lives you know it's just these
are just the things that happen I've got
a couple more questions left and
speaking on political consequences thank
you is there any consequence to playing
this game on ps4 its humanity friend of
the show asks I mainly want to know have
it handled technically on the
PlayStation 4 frame race detail load
time getting been getting some some
questions about this and and so my my
experience there were there were some
bugs and some framerate hitches and
performance little things like that and
the framerate never particularly
bothered me it drops a little bit here
and there
um mainly around cutscenes okay what
will happen is a cutscene will start at
all jitter around or you know it was
rare that I was like you know I was in
you know it doesn't really happen a lot
where you're in battle and suddenly it
slows down or something like that
whenever there's action the game
maintains a really good speed for the
most part on the ps4 to the point where
it never I was I never thought to myself
wow the frame rates making this a real
drag that never happened yeah I did run
into some some problems I didn't run
into what Jeff did was talk about about
the game crashing with Gwent I did run
into two system crashes when I played in
a hundred hours in a hundred hours and I
ran into early on there's a quests it's
your very first monster contract I did
things in a peculiar order and what
happened then is when I tried to
activate the final the final of fight
yeah it just led to a perpetual loading
screen oh so that was the biggest thing
I ran into um but that's because I I did
things in a weird order I've already
like reported that bug and hopefully
that'll get fixed maybe it'll even be
fixed for lunch for all I know I don't
know but other stuff was just little
stuff sometimes it's you know there was
one place where Roach who is your horse
start distantly lurching like for no
reason I'm just galloping through
Skellig on suddenly he's just like
lurching for half a second oh you got
the horse lurch yeah yeah and can cure
that with a potion and you know I think
eventually I just quick traveled away
and came back and everything was fine
right there visual bugs like sometimes
you quick travel and then you wait for
people like not everybody has has
appeared yet yeah um stuff like that but
I have another question for you Kevin
thank you for your answers sorry I get
off on Helvey de leyva wants to know
much has been said by you mr. vandorn in
florid detail about the side quests and
how wonderfully they enrich the world
but let's talk about the main quest a
little bit obviously it's going to be a
spoiler flee free situation but in terms
of I feeling like appropriately grand
and satisfying as kind of a them as the
it being designated main quest connotes
it was it satisfying is it it did you
like oh god I very much
actually um better which of two is
ending
yes The Witcher 2 had a terrible
terrible ending let's just lay it right
out there the entire third act of The
Witcher 2 felt completely unfinished
rushed um so and I've never really gone
back to any degree 2 and gotten to the
third act to see how much that's changed
for like updates and stuff this is a
very very different situation there's a
lot of arc like and I won't give
anything away but there's a lead up to
what seems like it so like kind of not
an ultimate battle it it but it is a
huge battle and then after that like
after like this kind of explosive thing
there's just a lot of bubbling as you go
to the Phanatic the actual finale like
it just builds and builds and builds and
the game actually warns you before you
get to the that big battle that certain
things are going to happen right okay
not go on and tell your your you're
ready almost teasing you to make you
think that you're going into the ending
but no no I pulls it ninokuni then yeah
and says no actually you thought this
was the final battle no you get a bunch
of more [ __ ] to do out there with the
story just go mmm that's constantly
you're kind of not really sure when it's
when it's crescendoing and when it's
like yeah but I mean it has definitely
an arc like it gets to that thing and
then that that's basically almost like a
catalyst and then it just Rises and
Rises and Rises after that but I'm one
of the things I love is just that it the
the moments that make the story what it
is our huge grand gestures and small
gestures to like I told you like what
when we saw that one of my favorite
things is that true Barret scene where
she's just singing in there it is the
quietest thing it is so beautiful it is
so romantic and I love that the game is
not afraid to have those you know to
have to have those things you know
comparing with each other all the time
like it's just a constant tug of war
between beauty and violence like all the
time that's what this world is really
about and so they they really hammer
that home with lots of small moments
lots of big emotions small emotions you
know I I loved the story a lot a lot
more than Witcher 2
which I felt like the abstract politics
weren't you know I liked that story a
lot but the abstract politics weren't as
nearly as involving as like as the
personal stories Kevin about Ord thank
you so much for coming on tell us about
the Witcher one last question to get us
out of here at some Tunnel II asks the
question everyone wants to know
I want a short answer for you sir chose
time any beard customization options are
we talking about here again you only get
to shave and you only get like two
haircuts [ __ ] so there's only
beardless or beard and the growth in
between the cool thing is that you get
it you get a shave and gross Sheryl
Crow's is beard yeah and then it does
feel a shave yeah I want 100 her beard
look like it's like ZZ Charlie is your
child and also eventually it just stops
growing and becomes like a very manly
gorgeous beard lighting up the like if
you wish you never seen like this no
this is not our example our example of
this graying neck beard is and I'm not
talking about grace I'll be doing cast
aspersions on grace I'm easily like the
oldest person in this office Oh Kevin
and yet you can still talk about the
best of them listening to you talk about
this game I'm like squirming with
anticipation for next week HTTP I may
also but that don't divulge that
information on internet Oh
you